how are they different with murray in
the lineup richard well you know he is
just
you know that scoring punch he is the
guy that can explode for
50 at any point in time and steph
curry's got
two three quick ones in the book so
unique i know he's a point guard but
look draymond has the ability
to find to drive to quit to pass here's
in the denver nuggets
do as good of a job as any teams in the
league you would know this is the
richard jefferson revenge game as curry
buries another one
six early for steph curry to this league
when he has that ball in transition
everyone is a threat it's an interesting
mix right now for golden state as steph
steps back into a three and buries it
can't double team as you see the denver
knuckles are on a 10-0 run
literally running riot out here steph
curry got another for three
you're right richard he wants to take
care of this 19 in the first quarter
and he's just look taking a time ball
pops out he's like all right all right i
tried to pass it
won't go and there is steph with the
rebound he is five short of the warriors
all-time record
in scoring and this pull up too short
he's too short and just here as you're
like he's five short as he's shooting
the ball you knew he was going to be too
short before that thing just dropped
i mean he has literally changed looking
arena
gotta recognize that aaron's in that
post and find another spot
steph curry a little jab and he knocks
down a three so welcome back into the
ball game steph curry
answers for the warriors here this guy
comes again yeah and that was just an ad
he took an extra step
missed it again and the rebound for
golden state a lot of one and done for
the nuggets
and draymond greens in a hurry this is
curry trailing for three
feel like that might have been an
important play for the nuggets
curry goodness wide open and he is
lethal
top then you just cut back door then
here
i don't know if that was a good screen
but at the end of the day steph curry
you know when you watch the nuggets here
in the second half
they they've really you know monte
morris
capazo their nuggets throw a couple at
steph curry
got away from porter with the pass they
thin out the defense from lee
cross court for curry step aside three
oh
yes